sie ist die berühmteste Hochstaplerin
der Welt Anna sorokine in New York hat
sie sich in die High Society hinein
betrogen sie hat sich Millionen
erschlichen und diesen Betrug dann bei
Netflix verfilmen lassen sie saß im
Knast dann in abschieberhaft jetzt soll
sie eigentlich irgendwann nach
Deutschland ausgeliefert werden ja aber
jetzt hat sie erstmal wieder die Welt
Öffentlichkeit gesucht sie hat CNN ein
großes Interview gegeben und das mit
einer elektronischen Fußfessel die Anna
sorokins Flucht verhindern soll und
jetzt in diesem CNN Interview da zeigt
sie diese Fußfessel auch her und sagt
dann in diesem Interview ja die war
ziemlich enger am Anfang die Fußfessel
sie dürfen ihre Wohnung nicht verlassen
und dann sagt sie auch ja sie bereue
alles sie habe sich entschuldigt die
sehen Sie Szenen aus diesem Interview
mit Jack Tepper von CNN wo sie gerade
eben die Fußfessel her zeigt das ist das
Ding ja und dann sagt sie sie wollen
eine zweite Chance in den USA und sagt
ich
ich bin jetzt eine andere Person
much
fix and a past and
say over every to
doing
Chance Battles die ja von einer neu
Erfindung spricht und sagt ich bin jetzt
eine andere Kind darüber sprechen wir
mit unserem Bild westkorrespondenten
Herbert Bauer Nebel in New York ich
grüße dich Herbert du hast das Interview
verfolgt natürlich wie weite Teile
Amerikas diese hochstapleren die vor
allem die Netflix weltberühmt wurde
jetzt steuerfindung dieser Frau so will
sich selbst zumindest eine Frau die alle
betrogen um den Finger gewickelt hat
kann man der ein bedauernden
Entschuldigung abnehmen und sagen okay
Anna du kriegst hier in den USA eine
zweite Chance
ja natürlich diese zweite Chance sucht
sie und hat auch dieses große Interview
dafür genutzt es ist natürlich schon ein
riesiger Auftritt im Eiern der größten
Nachrichtensender der Welt CNN wirft
natürlich auch ein wenig die Frage auf
warum dieses Schwergewicht check-taper
ausgerechnet einer sourcing jetzt zur
Interviewpartnerin gewählt hat aber
natürlich auch CNN weiß es ist ein
gewaltiger medienhyp hier entstanden um
einer solchen in den USA die
Medienberichterstattung über ihre
Entlassung war gewaltig und sie nützt
das natürlich mit einer neuen Botschaft
ich bin geläutet ich bin eine neue
Person ich verdiene eine zweite Chance
sie hat auch erklärt warum sie denn
nicht einfach nach Deutschland
zurückgeht wo sie in Freiheit leben
könnte sie und hier sagt sie ganz
deutlich im Interview sie möchte Fehler
gut machen hier in Amerika sie möchte
nicht kapitulieren vor dem Gesetz
sozusagen sondern hier eben versuchen
ein neues Leben aufzubauen eben in
dieser kleinen Wohnung in der sie jetzt
lebt ihm ist village
ja aus der kommt sie nicht raus eben
auch wegen dieser Fußfessel wir können
doch mal in diese Szene ganz kurz
reinschauen Herbert wo sie eben dem CNN
Interviewer dem Jack Tepper diese
Fußfessel zeigt dort und eben sagt das
war am Anfang ein bisschen eng jetzt
geht's einigermaßen jetzt habe ich mich
dran gewöhnt was hat das mit dieser
Fußfessel genau auf sich also wie
funktioniert die und ist das usus in den
USA haben das ganz viele dort in
Benutzung
es hängt davon ab wie der Richter
entscheidet und in Ihrem Fall hat er
entschieden dass sie eine Fußfessel
haben muss das soll der Fluchtgefahr
vorbeugen es ist ein elektronisches
Gerät wo eben ein Perimeter
einprogrammiert wird also eine Fläche
aus der sie sich nicht wegbewegen darf
das heißt wenn einer Sorge ihn jetzt
ihre Wohnung verlassen würde ohne dafür
eine Genehmigung zu haben würde diese
eigentlich Monitor also diese Fußfessel
anspringen und Alarm schlagen die der
dieser Perimeter ist sehr klein gewählt
worden eben nur seine Wohnung es gab am
Wochenende sogar Diskussionen ob es okay
für sie wäre ja hier am rooftop also am
Dach zu stehen Ihres Gebäudes was sie
getan hat für Fotoshoots all das wird
sehr genau überwacht abgeschaltet wird
der ankomme Monitor nur wenn sie am Weg
ist zu Behördenvertretern sie muss sich
ab und wann mit eben ihren parallel
Officer treffen und da wird eben diese
Fahrt zu diesem Gebäude genehmigt und
ebenfalls einprogrammiert ins System
also tausche Luxusleben gegen nur noch
die die Wohnung im Moment mit Fußfessel
dass das Leben von Anna Sorokin
beeindruckendes Interview dabei CNN und
darüber unser US-Korrespondent Herbert
Bauer Nebel danke dir
schöne Grüße nach Berlin
[Musik]